mercenary group presents itself as an
Elite Force in its propaganda
[Music]
these videos complete with Triumph and
music were filmed in the scarred
landscape of eastern Ukraine but
confessions made by men who claim to be
former commanders to a dissident Russian
human rights organization show a very
different sight
because
in this video ex-convict azamat uldarov
describes in disturbing detail how he
killed children
[Music]
foreign
the alleged atrocities happened in the
Donetsk region in the cities of solidar
and back moot
in January we saw firsthand what Russian
advances had done to civilian areas
Paul shelling had destroyed homes and
lives in another video Alexi savageev
reveals he was also ordered to kill
civilians including teenage boys by the
leader of Wagner yevgeni pragoshin
seen here in combat gear in another
Wagner video has denied the men's claims
and both have since retracted their
confessions although uldaurov has since
told the Human Rights group he was
threatened with violence to withdraw his
statements
but the alleged war crimes would fit
with a pattern of Russian atrocities
committed across Ukraine it will be
extremely important to analyze those
videos carefully obviously to ensure
that what they're showing is accurate
but we do know that literally wherever
Wagner and Wagner's troops are deployed
we see human rights abuses following and
so these are the very very kinds of
allegations that we see in many cases
places around the world
Ukrainian prosecutors are calling for
further investigations but a chance of
any justice for the victims and their
families remains remote Alex Rossi Sky
News